were you always like did you like did
your parents go M you're so funny um not
really oh my mom yeah I guess sometimes
did she say or no well I grew up at my
grandma's house and she would say like
like I'm a
smartass um cabon you know she spoke
what is cabon tell me it's kind of like
everything I mean from what I my
understanding of it is kind of just like
like [__] smart ass like right is
that the similar as chupacabra yeah it's
exactly the same you is nah okay little
bit okay um did you when did you get
your start um like an open mic I guess I
don't know what like in high school or
no no no I was like right out of high
school did you listen to him he said he
started at 19 I know 19 but I'm just he
was in high school and were you calling
him dumb I I've never
flunked there were 19-year-olds oh they
were yeah I didn't know there must have
been bad kids you know blun and Stu you
I got held back a year ah and not me I
was like real smart my teachers were all
was was like look at this
guy um yeah I was I was in Community
College I was trying to be an actor I
was like that's like going to be like a
theater major okay that's what I'm
saying so you did you do theater in high
school
no wait the wait you wait you would to
be an actor but you never took a class
or already they nah him U would would do
um what is that class called with the
cameras uh AV club AV club oh that's
super also you guys knew each other in
high school yeah what you say no you see
what I'm talking about H me get your
[__] together man like like grade oh
fourth grade yeah oh that's so cool but
that includes high school cuz
like it's okay Hae it's okay cuz like
you know you know each other from high
school he's like nah is he is he special
or I mean he's special to me okay good
that's my boy not not to everybody but
he was yeah okay he was doing like AV
club and uh he was talking about how the
school district had this like student
film festival thing and that the uh the
finalist in the competition would like
that final round would be held at um the
dollar movies do they have dollar movies
out here you know like I don't think so
anymore no right a movie made for a
dollar what are you talking about so
they're like um once you know how the
movies is like in theaters right after
it's they're not playing in theaters
anymore but before it comes out in DVD
it'll go to like the dollar movies
really yeah so like maybe you didn't
catch Spider-Man when it first came out
but five months later you could still
catch it at the dollar mov this a great
idea actually yeah and it's like it's it
wasn't really a dollar you know with
inflation and whatnot it was like a $150
two two bucks sometimes right but would
it be packed sometimes on Fridays yeah
bunch of little ghetto kids W also could
get violent yeah I guess so yeah yeah
but we I don't [__] go
Spiderman that right nah n they knew how
to watch a movie but anyway um
I thought it was cool if we made a short
film and we could like watch it at the
dollar movies it was like real big into
movies I just like a big fan or what so
like we made a movie and we got in there
and then um I I don't know I was like BR
I think like I could be like a funny
actor I always wanted to be like a
comedic actor yeah wait so you guys your
movie made it to the dollar movie or
just your a movie you were in no no no
his yeah like we made it together we
like so you guys made a movie got into
the Dollar Movie House yeah and how how
long was the movie it's a short it's a
short it's like 6 7 minutes or something
and did everyone show up to see it no no
no one can the other students that who
also movie was playing oh really Man The
girl who how many people were there how
many people were there like what 18 not
even 20 maybe 20 people oh man the girl
who won she made a movie about cancer
which that's [__] cheating but that's
true right yeah yeah anyway uh was it
good or no no wait hers or mine no hers
oh no hers was amazing and yours is not
good not at all what's yours about mine
was about a a guy that was like about to
go to jail and like he's just like
killing his last day kind of like it was
like a ripoff of like the 25th hour [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah [__] Ley he goes
hard man I like that
dude
um but I was like man I could I could
probably do like funny movies and stuff
and I looked up like different comedic
actors and I saw that like Adam Sandler
had went to um acting school like at NYU
or something M and I'm like well that
must be the start I mean I go to like a
university to Community College and took
acting classes and the the acting
teacher there told me about like he
asked me why why I wanted to do it and I
told him he was like oh you should also
try other like forms of Comedy like you
know improv standup comedy [__] like
that and I just went to open mic and I
really liked it so I didn't even go back
to like his class
anymore really yeah I didn't feel like
acting no more like this is it right
here like oh [__] it's okay I was like
stand up that's where it's at and
immediately your first time like you
felt it like oh like I really want to do
this well like I did and I didn't like I
went to the thing and I maybe went back
to a couple classes but I kept thinking
about the mic cuz I had you know it went
bad like really bad and so like right
after the mic I was just like well
that's not for me but then the next day
I was like nah n no I can figure it out
I can figure it out like if I say this
different if I say that differently
right and so I I ended up going back to
the mics like pretty quick and I just
didn't go back to the class wow your
very first time did you bomb or were you
like o like that was I mean no one liked
it but you know what I was I was proud
of myself because I got a lot of it out
of my mouth and also I the adrenaline
was racing through my body so it just
felt like